So the answer is over 3,000 years old. Humans
have been using networks like this since at least
as long as we can record. They might have
just been networks where people talk to each other, but
even networks where they were using technology to communicate,
in this way, go back at least 3,000 years.
So to give you an idea of how sophisticated
networks could be over 3,000 years ago, here's a quote
from Homer's The Iliad, where he's talking about the network
the ancient Greeks had. And they had a line of
beacons spread over the Greek islands. They could use that
to send messages, to warn the neighboring islands when there
was an enemy attacking, and that would tell them to
bring in their ships, that trouble's about to occur. And
Homer was writing this around 800 BC. But what he
was describing are wars that happened over 3,000 years ago.
And Homer wasn't just making this up. The Greeks actually had
such a network. They had a network where soldiers could light a
fire on one island and soldiers on another island would see
that fire. Light their own fire that would send a signal to
the next island. The next island would see that and light
its own fire. And they could send messages over great distances this
way. They could send a message over 600 kilometers across the Greek
islands. So what do you need to make a network like this?